Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies and
germs. This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to another
episode of The Tim Ferriss Show. And I'm going to
skip the preamble. I'm going to keep it light. My
guest today, my oh, my, do we have lots to cover
and I'm excited to dig in. My guest today is
Sheila Heen. This is her second appearance
on the podcast. Sheila has spent the last
three decades working to understand how people
can better navigate conflict with a particular
specialty in difficult conversations. God knows
we need more of that expertise for all of our
sakes. She is a founder of Triad Consulting
Group, a professor at Harvard Law School,
and a co-author of Thanks for the Feedback: The
Science and Art of Receiving Feedback Well (Even
When It Is off Base, Unfair, Poorly Delivered,
and Frankly, You’re Not in the Mood) with Douglas
Stone and Difficult Conversations, subtitle, How
to Discuss What Matters Most. Also with Douglas
Stone and Bruce Patton, with a newly updated
third edition that was just released in August.
Sheila and her colleagues at Triad work with
leaders and organizations to build their capacity
to have the conversations that matter most. Her
clients have included Pixar, American Express,
the NBA, the Singapore Supreme Court. Maybe we'll
talk about that. Who knows? The Obama White House,
and theologians struggling with the nature of
truth and God. She's schooled in negotiation
daily by her three children. You can find
my first and very popular conversation with
Sheila at tim.blog/sheilaheen. Sheila, nice
to see you again. Thanks for making the time.
Sheila Heen: It's great to see you.
Tim Ferriss: I know last time we spoke at length,
I was in the midst of a very challenging chapter
in my personal relationship. And when my team and
I reviewed the last conversation we had, which I
always do before a conversation like this, so went
through the entire round one. And there was a line
that stood out for all of us. And it might be a
paraphrase. You can feel free to fact check this.
Sheila Heen: Yeah, yeah. I can't wait
to hear what you're about to say.
Tim Ferriss: Quote, "It's not just that we have
difficult conversations in our most important
relationships. Those conversations are the
relationship." And I've been thinking about this
a lot in the sense that it seems like our most
important relationships are defined and steered
in large part by how we handle the difficult
conversations, how we handle things when we are
perhaps not our best selves. And to that extent,
they're what define a good or a bad relationship.
So I just wanted to share that, because it
stuck out for everyone who reviewed the last
conversation that we had on the side of my team.
How should we talk about — because we did discuss
a lot surrounding difficult conversations, and we
will edge into a lot of shared territory.
But how should we talk about feedback?
Sheila Heen: For me, when feedback is incoming,
part of what I'm doing is scanning for what's
wrong with it. And we can circle back to
this question because there's a great set
of things that are typically wrong with the
feedback, at least that other people give me.
So it's a shift from I have to decide whether
I agree or disagree, and what's wrong with it,
to before I decide, let me just understand it.
Let me just understand what they're trying to say.
So if we go to, what language does that suggest?
You can ask questions in one of two directions.
Feedback always has a past and a future. So you
can either ask more about where it's coming from,
like, "Say more about what you heard me say,"
or, "Can you give me an example of that?" or,
"Tell me more about the impact that had in
the exchange." So you're asking questions of
curiosity about, "What is it that you notice
that is prompting you to say this to me?"
The other direction that you can
ask questions in is forward-looking,
where is it going to. "If I were to take your
advice, what would I do differently? What
specifically are you suggesting or requesting?"
If I'm feeling particularly defensive,
that second set of questions is sometimes
easier. If I ask the backward-looking ones,
it'll suck me into an argument about
why they misunderstood, or misremember,
or that's not really what happened. If I just
go to, "Okay, if I were to follow your advice,
what would that look like in practice, in everyday
life?" And sometimes they have an instant reaction
and I realize, you're just saying — drop you
a note back to say, "I got it. I can do that."
If I thought, what we were talking about, "Am
I responsive in a fully human emotional way?"
you're just saying, "Just let me know whether
you got my note. You don't have to give me the
whole answer." Which is of course why maybe I'm
not responding yet because I'm like, "Oh, gosh,
that's a big question. Let me think about it.
I want to give you a good response." And you're
just saying, "Just let know you got it. You
can give the full response later." So that's
an example of, "I now understand what you want."
Sometimes the person doesn't know what they want,
but then that centers the conversation on, "Okay,
so I don't know how to change if you don't know
what would tell you that this is better."
Tim Ferriss: Right. There's phrasing from
the last conversation we had that came up multiple
times, which was, "Help me understand…" which I
thought was very skillful because it is basically
indirectly pointing the fingers at yourself,
if that makes sense. Rather than "Explain
yourself," "Help me understand" implies a
level of responsibility on the receiver that might
help to diffuse things or deescalate things. If
someone giving feedback comes in hot, so the
wording might be diplomatic, but the tone is,
"Listen, fucker, A, B, or C?"
Sheila Heen: Yeah,
it's amazing how clear that message is.
Tim Ferriss: Any thoughts for either how
to deescalate or self-talk that you can use so
that the person on the receiving end is able to
reply in a calm, cool, and collected fashion?
Sheila Heen: It could be that calm, cool,
and collected is more aspirational than realistic.
And one thing that can help is just to name the
surprise, or the, this just came out of left
field, I'm totally knocked off my center. So just
saying, "Wow, okay. Sorry, this is coming out of
left field, so I'm just kind of on my back foot,"
so that you're just naming where you're at in this
moment. And sometimes, just naming it can help you
find your feet again because you're like, "Okay,
I've just accurately described where I'm at. I can
be in that space," and now they know I'm in that
space. Or just saying, "Okay, I'm feeling a little
defensive." And then you can move to a question.
A question that I've been using recently that has
helped quickly get to the heart of what's going on
is, "What do you feel like I don't get? What is it
that you feel I really don't get about whatever?"
This situation, about how this impacted you,
whatever they're trying to tell you that
they feel like you're really clueless about,
that's often going to cut through the noise.
Tim Ferriss: So let's, if we could,
just jump into a real-life example. And perhaps
we could examine painful feedback from the past.
Sheila Heen: Your own?
Tim Ferriss: Well,
we can talk about my own. But I thought we would,
given my job as the inquisitor, I would ask —
Sheila Heen: That will not protect you, my friend.
Tim Ferriss: I know. It's not the flak
jacket I always hope it to be.
Sheila Heen: I know. I know.
Tim Ferriss: I came into this expecting that
I would be opening the kimono per se, but you
just finished the third edition of Difficult
Conversations, and you had to contend with some
reader feedback on an example in that book that
got large reactions. Could you elaborate on this?
Sheila Heen: So there were a lot of things that
we looked at fresh, and rewrote, and reworked,
and changed about the third edition. And one
of the examples that got the biggest and most
consistent negative reaction from readers
was an example, a story in the chapter about
shifting from blame to joint contribution.
And it's a sexual harassment example. And
although it's told to characters, because all
the examples in the book are real or amalgams,
but disguised. That particular
example was mine, and it came from an
experience that I had pretty early in my career.
I was in my twenties, I was sent abroad to work on
a project, international project. It was bringing
together consultants from lots of different
places. And simply because my organization was
the one that was holding the funding and in
charge of the project in the collaboration,
I got named as the team lead. And I was the
youngest person on the team by a good margin.
And so part of what happened, of course,
and we're in a very stressful context on site
in a divided ethnic conflict. So the task that
we have together, we have to come together,
build a set of team relationships that are
highly functional and adaptive in the moment as
things unfold. And so the first couple of days
are really spent sorting out, how do we connect
and how are we going to collaborate together as
we tackle getting ready for the project?
Over those first couple of days, things
settled down in terms of people's reactions to me
being the team lead. I'm sure their first reaction
was like, "Really? Because you look like you're
still in high school." And I had several decades
of experience, which was fair enough, honestly.
There was one guy who was particularly hostile
to the idea and continued to be hostile to
the idea. So I decide that the answer for
this to win him over and sort out whatever's
going on with his hostility to my leadership,
I'll assign us a piece of the next day to work on
together. And then we'll just have to sort it out,
right? Because we'll work on it one-on-one.
So I did that and it worked beautifully. I
soon learned that it had worked a little too
well, because he started saying things like, "I
feel like in another world we would've fallen in
love." He was indicating, directly and indirectly,
romantic interest. And I was completely freaked
out by that. And so I'd say, "I'm married." And
he said, "So am I. What's the problem?"
And oddly enough, I felt totally paralyzed
by it. And I'm not a shy person. I'm pretty quick
to speak up. In fact, that's some of the feedback
I'm getting now, which is I'm a little too
quick to speak up. We can circle back to
that. Now I just have the opposite problem. And
I felt like I'm sending the indirect signals,
and slightly more direct signals that I'm not
interested, and it's not stopping. And I'm
trying to avoid him, etc. He's always right
there. At any meal, he's right next to me.
And so I felt paralyzed because I felt like,
"Gosh, I have to be sure that I'm right about his
intentions, that I'm reading him correctly. Maybe
it's just a cultural difference between us." There
was no HR to go to, and it wasn't a hierarchical
thing. Some sexual harassment situations are
really tough, because it's in hierarchy
with a boss. Here, I'm actually in charge.
So the insight for me was, "Oh, gosh, I don't
need to be sure I'm right about his intentions.
I just have to describe the impact that it's
having on me," number one. And number two,
and the reason it's in the contribution
chapter, is that it suddenly started
occurring to me that I might have been sending
mixed signals by accident. In other words,
I arranged for us to do this piece of the project
together, and maybe that was signaling interest.
And so if I just change my contribution —
so my contribution to the problem was maybe
inadvertently seeming like I was reaching out to
give him special attention, because I was paying
attention to what he was doing to try to get him
in our meetings, to get him engaged, win him over.
And the other thing I'm contributing is I'm not
saying directly that I'm not interested, so I'll
change those contributions. So that was a big aha
for me. We disguise it, we write it into the book.
The reaction that we got was, we had one student
of ours who told us, "When I got to that part,
I threw the book across the room," which is
not really the reader reaction you're hoping
for. I don't know about you.
Tim Ferriss: What was the
explanation behind that, if there was one?
Sheila Heen: "You're blaming the victim. You're
blaming the victim. You are saying that she…" the
name in the book is Sydney, "...that Sydney is at
fault for her own situation, that she should
deal with it alone. In other words, she's got
to figure out what she needs to change, because
she got herself into this." And people also had
strong views about what was really going on with
him. They had strong views about what you should
do. "You should never have this conversation
directly. It's unsafe. You should go to HR." So
it was a very clear set of themes in the reaction.
By the way, what's your reaction as you listen?
Tim Ferriss: My reaction as I listen
is actually more a set of questions.
For instance, I'm very curious if the throw
the book across the room reaction is mostly
American-born-and-raised readers of a certain
vintage. I'm wondering if that's something
you have observed in readers from many other
cultures. I'm also wondering many other ages,
because it strikes me as though that may be a
very contemporary, industrialized US response,
or North American response to things, which
is just a hypothesis. But that's what comes
to mind from me from a curiosity perspective.
Sheila Heen: Totally. And what I particularly
like about your curiosity is that like me, it
allows us to locate the problem in them. "It's
just that you guys are either…" and I have this
reaction, totally, "...too young…" Like I was,
"...you'll get it once you're in the work world."
A big reaction was like, "Well, this just can't
happen. This should not happen," which I don't
disagree with. And it does. So the goal is, what
do you do about it? So some people were upset that
it was even in the book, because you shouldn't be
talking about these things. It's like, "Well, it's
a book on difficult conversations. So we want to
be tackling the ones that actually happen."
Tim Ferriss: We're not going
to choose the easy ones.
Sheila Heen: We're not going to choose
the easy ones. And if we don't have it, people
say, "Well, what about really hard situations
like sexual harassment? You don't address that."
So I agree with you that that reaction was coming
partly from — and it has morphed a little bit
over the years in terms of the generational
sense of what should happen in the ideal world. I
think when we're in our twenties as young adults,
we come into the world with a strong sense of
the way the world should work. And then, we
discover that that's not the way the world works
in many situations. And it's kind of outrageous.
And then we're like, "Why are we not changing
this? Why are you guys tolerating it?" And this
is why revolutions are led by young people.
And I think as I've gotten older, what I'm
noticing in myself is that okay, I address some
things and don't address others. But I also figure
out how to navigate the world as it is. And then
those of us in leadership have been successful in
the world as it is. And so we're like, "Don't
worry about it. You'll be able to navigate."
It's a lot better than what I was your age. But
I think that's partly why we get complacent,
because we do see the progress that's been made,
but then we can underappreciate the progress still
to be made. I'll also say that I want to be
fair to the other readers, some of whom were
young women from other cultures who have had even
more stressful, extreme, horrific experiences,
and were looking for guidance in feeling like
they were being told, "Well, you're on your own."
Tim Ferriss: I was going to just say before
we unpack some of the macro, and also the
example that you're about to give, which I don't
want you to lose track of, unless I missed it,
you didn't share how you ultimately address the
situation. So I feel like that's a critical piece
of the story. So in the original edition,
let's just say, how did you explain how you
then handled that very uncomfortable situation?
Sheila Heen: So part of what was so powerful for
me about realizing, "Actually, there are
a couple of things that I have done that
have probably contributed to this. And those I
have control over, those I can change." And that
was a relief. That was liberating for me, was,
"Oh, okay, well I can be clear about the fact,
even clearer about the fact. And I don't have
to know that I'm right about his intentions."
So I pulled him aside and said, "Hey, by the
way, I may not be reading you right at all.
So I'm not saying this is what you intend.
And you have made a number of comments about
having a romantic relationship or a personal
relationship. And I think I probably haven't
been clear that that's not of interest to
me. I'm enjoying our working relationship,
and that's super fun, and I think we're doing a
great job. But if I've been unclear, I apologize
for that." And that was kind of the end of it.
We only had another week or so of work to do
together, but I felt incredibly empowered. And
so therefore, when later readers are saying,
"You're blaming the victim and you're saying
it's her fault and that she's on her own," I
felt really misunderstood because I was like,
"No, no, no. We have a whole section of that
chapter that's about it's really important not to
blame the victim." And that a victim seeing some
contribution also gives them back some control and
power sometimes. It's not saying they did anything
wrong, you're not blaming them. They didn't do
anything wrong. And it helps them have a little
bit of control over making sure it doesn't happen
again in many cases, which was how it felt to me.
So when we're getting this feedback from readers,
I lost sight of what we're trying to do in a book,
which is that we're trying to put in stories that
resonate with people, where people are — we think
of writing as a conversation with the reader's
internal voice. And if we're doing something
that's creating a, "Wait a minute, that's not
true. That's not the way it was for me." Or,
"That's overstated." If we're creating
a reaction, it's going to get in the way
of the conversation that we're having because a
book is a one-way conversation. So we're trying
to anticipate what readers are wondering about
or objecting to or confused by or feel is off
base and then address it right away in the book.
So the good news was that we had an example that
was generating a lot of reader reaction that
people were bringing their own experience to.
That's good. But the fact that then it tells the
story as if there's one way to handle it, when
this was a relatively mild version that didn't
have power differentials in the way that many
people have faced, meant that I suddenly, because
it was my example, was feeling defensive and like,
"Well, you're misunderstanding me." And so we
did an interim fix where we tried to clarify
there was no HR, that this wasn't the only way to
handle it. The interim fix totally didn't work.
Tim Ferriss: So it wasn't clear in the
original edition that you did not have
HR or some intermediary to go to,
or it wasn't sufficiently clear?
Sheila Heen: We felt that it was clear. Yes, we
felt that it was clear. So that's the thing is we
felt that it was incredibly clear and that other
people were misunderstanding us. And we had a long
list of all the things that were wrong with their
reactions and understanding. So we tried to get
clearer and clearer with the example —
Tim Ferriss: And it didn't work.
Sheila Heen: It didn't work. It didn't
work at all. So what we needed to do,
which was what we finally did was say, "It's not
about my experience, actually. It's about what the
readers are bringing to their own life experience
and the felt pain that they want help with. And
this example, the way we're telling it is not
meeting them where they're at and is a particular
version which is not universal." So eventually,
in the third edition, we took it out. We replaced
it with a different example that got to the points
we were trying to make with it because we realized
that we're just creating more noise than help.
Tim Ferriss: Let me ask a question about that,
because the situation itself is
outside of my personal experience,
but receiving feedback on books —
Sheila Heen: Yes, is your personal experience.
Tim Ferriss: — and revising books is in my
personal experience. So I'm very curious,
did you receive strong positive feedback on that
particular example from other readers, or was it
pretty uniformly negative or confusion? Or did
you also receive a equal amount or comparable
amount of positive feedback from readers?
Sheila Heen: There were a couple of people
who came forward to say, "Oh, I actually really
loved that example. It immediately helped me see
situations where, 'Oh, I feel more empowered.'
I can see what I would do differently." I,
of course, remember those really clearly because
I hung onto them so tightly. They were definitely
way outweighed in this case. And you're raising
something that's super common, whether you're
a writer or just a human, which is, "You're
criticizing something, you hate this thing,
but actually don't you understand that's the best
part of me? That's what everybody else loves."
And so you get conflicting reader feedback.
Tim Ferriss: Could you say more about that?
The part that other people like about
you is that sort of contribution and
reclaiming of agency, is that what you mean?
Sheila Heen: No. That often the things that we
get feedback about from some people, our reaction
is like, "Okay, well, that's just contradictory
because everybody else is telling me that that's
one of the things that they love about me."
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Sheila Heen: So talk to me by the way about
reader feedback that you get because I do think
it goes into different buckets. Some is just,
well, people have different preferences.
And so some people love this part, some
people hate this part or wish it were different.
Tim Ferriss: I should say a few things. The first
is that I try to, in the case of reader feedback,
which is different from proofreader feedback,
they're very different, because when I reach
out to proofreaders, I know the sample size.
If I reach out to 10 proofreaders, I can
look at which responses are positive,
negative, neutral, 10 out of 10. But when
you get negative feedback or criticism,
there's a selection bias. If you are operating a
customer service hotline, chances are that people
who are thrilled with their experience are not
going to be the ones who call in or they're going
to be far fewer. So it's easy to sometimes
perceive that something is being uniformly,
across the board, criticized when in reality,
for instance, this has happened in the podcast
where I've talked about certain things that I've
done or said that have come under fire, and then
people come out of the woodwork to say, "Hey, we
are actually the silent majority who think it's
great or totally fine, but we're not the ones who
are on Twitter yelling and screaming about it."
So I just want to point out that sort of selection
bias that I try to be aware of with. I pay more
attention to proofreader feedback generally than
I do reader feedback. I pay attention to both. For
instance, I was just giving someone this example
last night, The 4-Hour Workweek came out in 2007,
and there was a quote at the head of a chapter
from Bill Cosby about breaking the rules that
are set for you in an industry. And thank God
that a number of readers pointed out maybe that
should be taken out for the next printing. And
of course I agreed with that and took it out.
Sheila Heen: Yeah, it quite differently.
Tim Ferriss: There's no upside to that.
Only downside. It detracts from the point I'm
trying to make and it's a distraction, not an
addition. There's really no upside for the reader
or for me in having that in. With proofreaders,
and this will tie into the reader feedback, I
am sending, say, a given chapter or chapters
to professional writers who are friends of mine
who ideally have different sensibilities also to
non-professional writers, so let's just call them
lay audience readers. And I'm generally asking,
first and foremost, what do you find confusing?
Highlight anything that is unclear or confusing.
Second, highlight if I could only keep 20 percent
of this chapter, what I should absolutely keep.
And then if I had to cut 20 percent, have to,
which 20 percent would you cut? And my rule
with the proofreaders is if one person among my
small selection I've selected for good reasons,
if they love it, stays in. And take
something out usually requires a
pattern. So if more than one person says,
"Take this out, it's slow, it's slow,
it's confusing, it doesn't pull its own
weight," whatever that happens to be,
then I take it out. Those are my three biggest.
I mean, if I added one more on, I would say,
please note in the margins or in the document
anywhere your mind starts to wander. So anytime
you start thinking about your to-do list or your
email or something else, that's an indication that
I'm not building sufficient traction and momentum
in the piece to keep you engaged and I have to fix
that. Those are the things I focus on.
Sheila Heen: The connection is broken
between the voice of the book and the reader.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly. It's just not compelling
enough. So I pay attention to those things. And
there are some revisions that I've made over time
where again, there's not enough value and upside
to the reader or anyone else to justify a counter
argument on my part. For instance, in The 4-Hour
Workweek, again, I used the word "retarded" at one
point, and it's not going to personally offend
most people reading it, but it is outdated,
and it just wasn't necessary. It wasn't a critical
piece of a story. I could take it out. I didn't
feel like I was compromising the integrity of
the writing by taking it out, so I took it out.
But in the case of your example, I would love to
know how you personally feel about it, about the
revision and the editing of that. Because for
instance, as I think about my preparation right
now that I am undertaking for trips starting
next week where I'm going to be off the grid
in some very remote, in some cases possibly
dangerous environments, I'm going with someone
who's former military. It's a long story that
I won't get into, but part of our conversation,
largely directed by him, has been what we
should wear, how we should pack, specifically,
to minimize the likelihood of being a target, and
different types of behavior, different types of
decision-making that are intended to minimize
the likelihood or reduce the likelihood of bad
things happening. From my perspective, it would
be irresponsible not to have that conversation.
And I'm grateful to have someone on my team who
has a lot of experience in these environments.
So this is just a way to say, I could say,
well, these bad things shouldn't happen,
or these aggressors shouldn't have aggressive
behavior, but these things do happen. They will
continue to happen. And so for me,
it's a question of risk mitigation,
and of assuming some degree of agency so that
we don't feel like a piece of driftwood being
thrown around in an unpredictable sea entirely.
But how did you end up feeling about making the
revision? And by the way, I'm not saying you
should or shouldn't have made the revision, I'm
just curious how it sits with you after the fact.
Sheila Heen: Mixed, of course. On the one hand,
relieved, we wrote every different possible
version to try to fix it as possible. And it's
just like, it's just not good. It's not serving
our purposes. And it might be too close to home,
too personal, so that my sense of it is muddied
and we really need to hear the impact that it's
having, which is not helping our cause. And it is
such an important issue for so many people these
days, male and female, that it feels to me like a
conversation about all of the ways in which that
feels painful and we can feel powerless and stuck,
et cetera. It feels like an important topic.
And it's a conversation that I have with people
a few times a year who come to me to say,
I need help with this situation. So I'm mourning
a little bit that loss and I'm at the same time
persuaded the use of that particular example in
this context was not helping. So let's just let
it go and let me think about what I need to
learn about my own need to somehow have the
particularities of my experience feel heard by
readers rather than saying, the purpose is to
bring forward your own. So that's the point
here. And Sheila, you're missing the point.
Can we circle to the proofreader feedback, right?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, sure. And also, I asked you to
bookmark something that we can come back to or
not, but you mentioned women overseas, maybe not
solely women, but who have contended with much
more extreme examples of your situation. So if
we wanted to come back to that, happy to come back
to it. But yes, we can also talk about proofreader
feedback. So however you want to lead us.
Sheila Heen: Let's go to proofreader feedback
because one of the things I really love about
how clear you are with your proofreaders is that
you are implicitly letting them know what kind
of feedback you're asking for. This is one of
the typical mistakes that we make, which is that
we say, "Hey, could you take a look at this and
give me some feedback?" Do you have any feedback
for me is an incredibly hard question to answer.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, very ambiguous.
Sheila Heen: Very ambiguous. It's like, how honest
should I be? Should I have prepared, et cetera.
Tim Ferriss: And if these people are your friends,
well, I choose my friends these days, I
would say with one critical leg of the
stool being their ability and eagerness to give
me what might be considered difficult feedback,
call my baby ugly if need be to save me some pain
later. But early on, and I'm sorry to interrupt,
but just to offer a contrast early on, I would ask
friends of mine to read and give me feedback in
just as many words. And many of them assumed I was
looking for moral support. So they would be like,
"Oh, I really liked this and this and this." And
they'd leave out the fact that they couldn't make
any sense of three other things and really hated
two other things. But I was not surgical in my
request. So they gave me what they inferred I
wanted, which was a pat on the back and a pat
on the head. And that's not actually what
I was asking for, but that was my fault.
Sheila Heen: Yes. And I think that's a big
thing that I have learned from the feedback
work. When you say "my fault," what do you mean?
Tim Ferriss: Well, I felt a little resistance
there. Yes, they could have, if
they had been more proactive,
they could have asked me to refine or they could
have taken a role in teasing out a more precise
request. So I don't want to put it all on me,
but I also fumbled the ball. So they could have
picked it up, but I also fumbled it a bit.
Sheila Heen: I think you're exactly right,
which is to have a rich and meaningful feedback
conversation, there's responsibility on both
sides. And you are pretty clear, and your
friends have learned, the ones who didn't
learn didn't make the cut anymore, so they
have learned what you value in terms of pretty
candid coaching and evaluation.
Tim Ferriss: And actually,
may I add one more thing?
Sheila Heen: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The people who are best at
giving feedback, they will sometimes ask
for further refinements in my request.
Sheila Heen: Yeah, clarification.
Tim Ferriss: They'll be like, "Okay, well, when
you say this is what you're really looking for,
this or this," they will drill
down until they're like, "Yes,
I can repeat back exactly what you're asking of
me." Great. Deadline, next Monday. Perfect. And
then they're on it, something like that.
Sheila Heen: And I think it takes that
exchange. So you, I'm sure you have this
experience, which I also have, which is
that other people hand me their manuscripts. This
was true two weeks ago and say, could you take a
look at this and give me some feedback? And I
have learned that I need to say more. Can you
say more about what would be helpful to you at
this stage? And just to put a finer point on it,
one of the things that has really helped me is to
understand that there are really three kinds of
feedback. We need all three over time to learn
and grow, but we might need different types at
different times. And the first is appreciation.
And sometimes with a manuscript at the stage it's
at, what you need to know, is there anything
here of value? What do you like here? Because
I just need a little encouragement to keep going.
And I think the appreciation plays a huge role in
our willingness to stay engaged over time in the
relationship. If I feel like you really see me
and get how hard I'm working or there are things
that you like and appreciate about me even in the
midst of us having some struggle. The second kind
is coaching. Coaching is anything designed to help
it be better, help me be better. You are being
really clear with your readers. Tell me what's
confusing. Coach me on where I'm not being clear.
And coaching course is the big engine for learning
and change and improvement. But you're also
actually asking for the third kind of feedback,
which is evaluation, like rate or rank it.
And what you're saying is there's a standard
for what stays and what goes. Tell me what
must stay like it well meets the standard for
being essential. Tell me what doesn't make the
cut in your view. And that's actually helpful
to me. So you're actually asking primarily
for coaching and evaluation in your request,
and when people are that clear about what they're
looking for, it's so much easier to respond.
Tim Ferriss: If I could just bounce off of that a
few things. First is that I will also frequently
not ask someone to check all of those boxes.
Sheila Heen: Right. Often it's one thing.
Tim Ferriss: You're right. When I'm asking
professional writers especially they have
their own deadlines, they have their own work.
Reading my stuff is not their job, so I'm asking
them for a favor. Very often I'll ask them to
just indicate the 20 percent that has to go or
the 20 percent that has to stay or just indicate
what is unclear or slow where you start to think
about other things. And I'll make up for the
lightness of that request by adding more people.
I'll just have more proofreaders instead of more
requests per proofreader. And I should also say, I
want to give credit where credit is due. So Steven
Pressfield, incredible writer in his own right and
has written The War of Art and many other books,
talks about resistance. And he became an informal
coach/therapist when I was working on fiction for
the first time about, let's call it a year ago.
And I sent him some very early drafts and asked
him for feedback being, I think in some respects,
masochistic. I asked him to just vivisect my work.
And his response was basically, "I've read it,
I want to read more, just keep going." And
what I gleaned from that was that he said,
"That's great kid. I recognize that you want me
to tear this apart and that's not what you need
right now. So I'm actually going to give you the
appreciation, not the coaching and evaluation.
I'm going to give you the pat on the back and
the kick in the ass just to keep going because
actually that's what you need right now." And
he was right. Of course, I'm speculating a lot
about his inner experience, but that's I think the
intention behind the feedback that he gave me. So
how do people take this framework, the three kinds
of feedback and put it into practice, I suppose?
What are some ways that people might think about
carrying that into their day? They listen to this,
they carry it into their day or their week.
Sheila Heen: Yeah. Well, one thing that helps
is just to be clearer about what you're short on
right now or what you're asking someone for. Or if
you're being asked to give feedback, to ask them
and maybe not trust their answer. What I hear him
saying is, implicitly we're speculating, maybe, "I
think what you just need is the encouragement to
keep going right now." He could also be thinking
in the early stages of any fiction, there are a
hundred things wrong with it, but you don't figure
out what they are until you're further down the
road and you are coming back and revising. So
you're just not at the stage that's a good match
for specific coaching because you just need to
keep going. Once you see where this arc goes,
you'll back up and see and figure out what needs
to change, who knows? He's got some philosophy in
his own head. In terms of getting specific about
things you can do with this framework of types
of feedback, they have different purposes. Easy
way to remember them is ACE, A-C-E, appreciation,
coaching and evaluation. We need all three.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just perhaps spend a
little more time differentiating between coaching
and evaluation? Because I could see mixing those
up. I could see personally mixing those up.
I think of coaching as part of evaluation.
So how should we distinguish those two?
Sheila Heen: They often get tangled. And
often I'm very clear that what I'm offering
you is coaching for reasons that have to do
with your personality problems. You're hearing
it as judgment or evaluation. So there's often
a mismatch between what the giver thinks
they're doing and what the receiver hears.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it happens a lot.
Sheila Heen: And partly that reflects the
fact that packed into, implicit in any coaching,
is a little bit of evaluation. Because if I'm
giving you a suggestion on how to do it better,
it suggests that you could be doing it better. And
so we hear that, which hits an identity thing.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. So is coaching the what and
the how of improving, whereas the evaluation is
basically fail/pass, A+. It's basically giving
someone a value judgment on their work.
Good enough, not good enough. And then
the coaching is here are the steps to take.
Sheila Heen: Yeah. So we have some set of
standards for whether this manuscript is ready to
go, is it ready to go out or not? What standards
for performance expectations? In this role,
here's what we would expect from you. Grades,
obviously. Here's what I'm looking for in terms
of the quality of your work. So yes, evaluation is
rating or ranking against some set of expectations
or standards how you measure up. So just asking,
"Am I on track for what you expected from me
in this new role?" So the question of "How is
this going in our relationship?" is often,
"How are you feeling about whether this is
still exceeding your expectations?" or starting
to feel wanting. That goes along with a whole
bunch of coaching potentially for what I wish you
would do. So the two are very closely related,
but we have the biggest emotional reaction to
the evaluation part because we hate being judged.
It's hard. It's really hard to feel judged.
And so we're quick to hear it in anything.
Tim Ferriss: I was looking at some of the prep
notes and one tactic, or maybe it's more of a
practice that I'd love for you to describe, is
the phone a friend. Because this seems like a
low-risk, high-reward way to cultivate the ability
to look at things from multiple perspectives and
to receive feedback well. So the supportive
mirror, the honest mirror. Could you describe
for folks what the phone a friend means here?
Sheila Heen: So part of the challenge of
receiving feedback is, as I think I mentioned
a little while ago, when feedback is incoming,
formal or informal, I'm scanning for what's wrong
with it. As human beings, we're very good at wrong
spotting. What they're saying isn't true. That's
not exactly how it happened or in the context,
that wasn't what was going to help. Who is giving
it to me? There's all kinds of problems. I don't
like them. I don't trust them. I don't want
to be like them. They don't know what they're
talking about. Why I suspect they're giving it
to me. They've got their own agenda for how they
want me to change. When and where and how they
gave it to me was outrageous and ridiculous.
So if I can come up with what's wrong with it,
then I can safely set it aside and relax and go
on with my life. And the problem with that is that
you're always going to be able to find something
wrong with the feedback that you get. And it could
be 90 percent wrong, but that last 10 percent
might be just what I need to be thinking about in
order to change and grow. So for instance, what
they understood happened and why I did it doesn't
make sense and their suggestion for what to do —
It doesn't make sense, and their suggestion
for what to do instead wouldn't work. However,
maybe the 10 percent is that they're
highlighting that this is maybe a bigger
problem than I thought it was. I have my own
diagnosis and I'll come up with my own solution,
but they're putting something on my plate
that maybe wasn't as visible to me before.
Part of the skill of becoming a better receiver
is not letting my triggered reaction and my wrong
spotting be the end of the story to throw it all
out, but instead to first work to understand the
feedback. Then I can decide and sort what is
right about it and what's wrong with it. Now,
that's really hard for me to do by myself for
a bunch of reasons in terms of the challenge to
see what the giver means and the challenge
to see myself accurately and all of that.
And so I can phone a friend to help. By the way,
I'm going to phone a friend anyway. When I get
upsetting feedback, I'm going to go complain to
somebody else about it. Right? Over a glass of
wine. And we're going to make a big list about
what's wrong with this other person and all the
ways in which they're wrong. And so what I can do
is I can reach out to somebody I trust, which I'm
going to do anyway and I'm implicitly asking
them to be what we call a supportive mirror,
to join me in seeing what's wrong with it.
Because if I'm really devastated by it,
I'm not in a place where I can learn anyway. This
one thing and this one mistake is the whole story
about me. And I'm so knocked off balance that —
Tim Ferriss: Or if you're just
annoyed enough that you're spun up.
Sheila Heen: Spun up, and rejecting it, and pissed
off. Right? Absolutely. This is just more evidence
of what's wrong with them. I'm not in a great
place and I need somebody else to join me in just
getting myself back to a place where I can maybe
hear what might be right about it. Asking a friend
two questions. Ask you two questions and help you
process in two directions. One is what we're doing
naturally, which is be as supportive mirror. Join
me in asking what's wrong with this feedback.
And then when I'm ready — usually, we quit there
and go home because now we feel better. In the
meantime, our friend is thinking it's not totally
off base. And so we need to give them permission
to then when we're ready to shift and be what
we call an honest mirror and to help us see what
might be right about it. What might be legitimate
and maybe hard for me to see when we have a visual
for the supportive mirror, it's like a gold gilded
frame. Show me at my best in flattering light.
They're wrong. I'm okay. I'm fabulous. And we do
need that. It's important not to skip it.
Tim Ferriss: And what might be right
about it is more like black mirror.
Sheila Heen: It's like a black mirror.
The mirror that we often use is actually —
you know that hand mirror that you find in
barbershops or hair salons?
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Sheila Heen: And the reason — also black mirror.
The reason we use that shape of mirror is because
when the barber or the hairstylist shows it to
you, they're showing you the back of your head.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, right. When they walk behind you.
Sheila Heen: They spin you around
so that you can look in the mirror and see, you
can appreciate what an amazing job they did. But
they're actually handing it to you to help you see
something that you can't see by yourself. Being an
honest mirror is asking a friend to help you see
what might be right about this feedback. What do
you think I should probably hear embedded in it?
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so I definitely encourage
people to do this. I mean, I naturally do
this with a number of my close friends,
is ask them for that barber spin
around, look at the back of the head.
Sheila Heen: Right. Right. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Here's a question that
is not directly related, but it's certainly
thematically aligned with what we're talking
about in this conversation. Also, what
we talked about in our last conversation,
things have changed since we last spoke. I am back
in the singles arena and one thing that has struck
me is almost no number of dinners every one or two
weeks, where everyone's on best behavior allows
you to see what people are like in difficult
conversations. Unless it's heavily engineered,
it's unlikely to come up organically. Unless, who
knows, the waiter spills tomato juice on her dress
and she freaks out and smashes a glass on the
floor and starts yelling at people. Okay, fine.
Sheila Heen: You're like,
"Well, thanks for the clarity."
Tim Ferriss: But I haven't yet architected
something like that. But I am curious to know,
and I'll give a counter example
actually. I'm not going to name names,
but I was at the dinner with someone I know who,
last I saw him, was actually, he was single,
then decided he wanted to find a partner and
basically made a commitment to every — he had a
one-pager. He would show each person on a date
and he'd be like, "What do you think of this
one-pager? This is what I'm looking for."
Sheila Heen: Oh, my gosh. What is
on the one-pager? We have to know.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I don't want to dox him,
but a lot of women opted — nothing crazy, but
he wants a lot of kids, as an example. A lot
of women opted out and he's like, "Great, I don't
want to waste your time." And that was that. Some
were like, "Actually, this is very interesting."
And if he decided that he wanted to give someone
a serious shot, he would say, "I can make
a commitment to you, which is in six months
we'll either be engaged or we'll be separated.
I won't drag this out for a really long time."
But his approach is then to spend a lot
of time with that person. Basically,
try to effectively move in with them for two
or three weeks and see what happens. I don't
know if I'm ready to make the jump to that
end of the spectrum, but it does make some
sense in so much as fiddling around seeing each
other intermittently, not really getting a good
read of how someone handles conflict or difficult
conversations or life when they are compromised,
like rundown, low on sleep. Seems like it could
waste a lot of time and you could just go on
these multi-month boondoggles without either
side getting a super clear read of the other.
Do you have any thoughts on how to figure this
out sooner? I mean, I certainly have had the
experience of say going on a week long trip with
someone and you see how they handle their luggage
getting lost or whatever it might be. But are
there any other simple or elegant or obvious
approaches that I'm just missing where maybe you
could suss out a bunch in a conversation over
dinner and I'm just not finding the path of least
resistance with questions that really deliver?
Do you have any thoughts about any of this?
Sheila Heen: First I'll note the efficiency
orientation toward dating.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Well,
I'm not getting any younger. Right?
Sheila Heen: I know, I know. Seriously.
I mean, I'm not actually saying it's
wrong at all, but it's the lens.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Sheila Heen: Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yes. You've named the lens.
Sheila Heen: The 4-Hour —
Tim Ferriss: Guilty as charged.
Sheila Heen: The 4-Hour Relationship —
Tim Ferriss: Courtship.
Sheila Heen: — Assessment. Yes,
Courtship. Exactly. That's your
next book. Maybe it's fiction.
Tim Ferriss: Got a ways to go before I'll
feel remotely qualified to write anything.
Sheila Heen: And I think you're exactly
right, which is early in the relationship,
we're all on our best behavior. And sometimes not
because it's hard, but because we're just excited
and appreciated and flooded with all of the
positive feelings. How we handle stress and how
we handle conflict doesn't come up for a while.
At least experientially doesn't come up unless,
as you say, you happen to see it because something
happens while you're together with someone else
who they don't have this protective, positive
set of feelings about. Whether that's because
you're traveling together or something
happens with the restaurant. And I would
say that that's a big red flag, obviously.
Tim Ferriss: If they freak out and start
screaming at the wait staff?
Sheila Heen: If they freak out.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Sheila Heen: Yes. It's funny because sometimes
it should freak us out when they don't address it
at all too, because that's not actually going to
be good in the longterm in relationship because —
Tim Ferriss: Yep, that's fair.
Sheila Heen: — it's like, "Well, that's great,
but now you're not going to say something with
me." Some of it is that it's a topic. I mean,
even when we are interviewing teaching fellows,
because we work together in a pretty intense
January term where we're together from 9:00
to 5:00, 6:00, 7:00, 8:00 preparing for the
next day because it's an intense three-week
term. Class all day, every day.
One of the questions we ask is,
"Talk to me about how you experience and handle
stress. What stresses you out and what helps you,
and what doesn't help you?" Similarly, "Talk
to me about how conflict was handled in your
family or in your past relationships in ways that
felt right to you or that have felt frustrating
or dysfunctional to you?" I mean, it's a really
interesting and rewarding topic of conversation.
Whether their espoused theory for what they think
they do matches what they actually do, sometimes
they don't exactly. What we think we're doing is
not what other people actually see. However, it at
least puts on the table what they think they do.
How would you answer those questions in terms of
how you handle conflict and stress and what helps?
Tim Ferriss: How I personally handle
conflict and stress?
Sheila Heen: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I owe my ex a huge debt of gratitude
in the sense that I think on many levels she was,
and is, very emotionally intelligent. Very,
very, very socially intelligent. I learned
a lot through osmosis and through coaching. I
was not always the most enthusiastic recipient
of said coaching, but nonetheless.
Sheila Heen: It's like, "I'm sorry,
I was not realizing that I had
hired you for this evening." Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, so I would say
I tend to address conflict openly. And we may
come back to what you mentioned earlier where
some people have given you the feedback that
you're too quick to speak up. I do, and this
has been consistent for a very long time. We spoke
about this in the last conversation, but timing of
those conversations matters a lot for me late at
night when I've had a full, after a full day when
I'm getting ready to wind down and I already have
issues with an overactive mind and onset insomnia
is not going to generally have the best outcome.
Experimenting with other times, shorter duration,
start and end time type of quick check-in
clearing conversations is very effective for me.
I have found the book Getting the Love You Want
and some of the frameworks asking for redos,
having a shared language that allows you to,
I suppose, resolve things with shorthand,
but agreeing upfront that you are going
to have that shared language and those
practices at least for a period of time as
an experiment, I think is super helpful.
I feel like I handle conflict reasonably well. In
my household though, to answer that part, I would
say I had, and this may not be totally fair, but
I think it's a decent read. I had one, maybe the
term that you would use is a blame absorber
in the form of my mom, very conflict-averse,
quick to apologize for everything. And then
my dad, and if he's listening, sorry, dad,
but blame deflector in the sense that things
tended to be taken very personally, tended to
get very heated, very defensive. "Why is everyone
always ganging up on me or fill-in-the-blank?"
To that extent, I had an easier time interacting
with my mom than my dad. But both of those
coping mechanisms or strategies I have found
myself using, and neither of them works very
well. The deflecting, for reasons that are
perhaps more obvious. The blame absorbing,
I would say oftentimes because if I want a
conversation to end, if the ask isn't clear,
if for instance, I'm being given coaching, but
there are no examples that can be provided and I
just see no resolution in sight, I am inclined to
apologize just to make that conversation go away
because I don't see it going anywhere helpful.
But then if I find myself doing that repeatedly,
and this is true for a lot of people, not just
me, having a stewing resentment that develops
because the apologies aren't really, one could
say sincere. One could say, not really deserved
possibly in some instances. Right? It's a way
to take the exit ramp off of this highway of
fruitless conversation or debate or argument.
I would say I did not grow up with great models
in the household. However, I would credit my time
in sports and having coaches I really respected
with helping me to accept coaching quite easily,
including very harsh old-country-style feedback.
Jerzy Gregorek comes to mind, who's this former
world record holder in Olympic weightlifting who's
an incredible coach, incredibly good at rehab
and addressing injuries. His style of feedback,
to give you an idea, at one point we were having
a conversation early on over black tea. This is
the intake conversation in California a long
time ago. And he was looking at me sort of
narrowing his eyes as he drank his black tea, and
he reached across and he kind of pinched my pec,
almost grabbed my nipple, gave it a
pinch, and he leaned back and he said,
"You are too fat." But the guy has the bonafides.
Right? He's a real performer. He has an excellent
track record and I was like, "Okay. Let's call a
spade a spade. Yeah, I could probably do without
the late night pizza binges after having maybe one
or two glasses of wine that I shouldn't have had."
Sheila Heen: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah,
okay. I could put up a fuss, but this guy is very
straight. He's not exaggerating. His tone is very
matter of fact. He's not saying it in some kind
of finger-wagging, holier-than-thou way. It's
just a statement of objective fact, so fine.
And so I would say that I feel very fortunate
that in a sports capacity, and also why I think
mandatory sports are an excellent, excellent idea
for youth in general, I became very comfortable
with fast direct feedback in those settings.
The way that I navigate conflict and feedback
is very context dependent. And I would say that
over the last five years, the way that I am
able to metabolize comfortably feedback and
elicit feedback in my intimate relationships
or personal relationships, let's say, has
become much closer to what I'm able to do in the
sports or skill acquisition arena. I can do that
with language and other things as well. It's not
just physical sports. That's the long story long,
I guess. I'm happy to keep going though. If you
want to keep me in the hot seat. I kept you in the
hot seat for a while, so certainly if there's
more digging we can do, I'm happy to do it.
Sheila Heen: Well, so one of the things that
strikes me, a couple of things that strike me.
One is your experience with him and also with
the guy that you're going to be traveling with.
Tim Ferriss: With Jerzy.
Sheila Heen: With the coach, and also the
guy that you're going to be traveling with, who's
coaching you on what to pack and what to wear and
how to stay under the radar. You are hiring them
with that specific job in mind. You're hiring them
because you believe that they have expertise and
you are eager to hear their coaching. It's not
always easy to hear, but the role is clear.
Tim Ferriss: The friend is just a friend who
happens to come with the benefit of being someone
A, I really, really respect as an operator in the
world, which is important to how I —
Sheila Heen: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: — very relevant to how I receive
feedback. Who's better than me in so many
departments, more skilled than I am, more
practiced than I am in so many capacities that
it's very easy for me to receive his feedback,
which is also very brief, very understated,
very direct, says it with a smile. It's not just
the content, but the tone also is very matter of
fact. Yes, but it's part of my expectation in
those relationships, that that type of feedback
is something I value very highly.
Sheila Heen: And so that's one of
the conundrums of feedback is why is it
that sometimes we're so eager for it,
and even when it's rude and surprising
with a pinch, we're grateful for it a
little faster. We're like, "Okay, fair,
fair. I'll take that on board." When other
times somebody else could do the same thing —
Tim Ferriss: But if I were on a second date
and I were really into some chick and she reached
across and pinched me, and she was like, "Wow! You
are too fat." I don't think I'd take it as well.
Sheila Heen: Yeah, no to future
dates. Just cross that off your list.
Tim Ferriss: Very unlikely to happen, but the
exact same feedback, different person, different
place, I would feel very differently about it.
Sheila Heen: Absolutely, so this is one of the
conundrums, by the way, of feedback, which is why
is it that sometimes I actually, it does feel like
a gift and I'm grateful for it. And other times
it's like, "Yeah, screw you. We're done."
Tim Ferriss: "You're dead to me."
Sheila Heen: "You're dead to me, and we don't
even need to finish dinner. And speaking of
sexual harassment, stop pinching my pec."
We're going to come full circle here. I'll
maybe make a general observation and then I
want to go back to your parents a little bit,
too. But the general observation is that one of
the things that we start to notice is that when
we have a reaction to feedback, there are sort
of three kinds of triggered reactions we have.
One is what we call a truth trigger. What
you're saying isn't right, wouldn't work,
but good/bad advice, it's all about evaluating
the quality of what the person is telling you
would help you. The second is what we call a
relationship trigger, which is everything to
do with who's giving you the feedback. Whether
you trust them, whether you like them, whether
you think they know what they're talking about,
whether they really have your best interests of
mind or their own agenda. We often have a
bigger reaction to the who than the what.
And then the third is what we call an identity
trigger, which is partly the story we tell about
who we are and whether that feels threatened or
not. But also in the course of the feedback work,
we uncovered some evidence that suggests
that in terms of sensitivity to feedback,
how upset we get and how long it takes
us to recover, that can vary by up to
3,000 percent. And so some of it is just —
Tim Ferriss: Can you say that one more time?
Sheila Heen: That our sensitivity to feedback and
other things happening in our lives, by the way,
it's not just feedback, but in terms of how upset
we get, how activated we get, and how long it
takes us to recover. You lying awake in the wake
of the argument, which is partly what's wrong. The
arguments are partly who's the problem, which one
of us is the problem, and which one of us needs
to change, in many cases. How long it takes us to
recover can vary by up to 3,000 percent. And so
that is just the way we're wired. Some of that
is past experience or something around trauma
that gets tripped, that changes your sensitivity.
Part of the challenge is understanding I am having
a triggered reaction to what's happening,
whether that's feedback or conflict,
and in what ways is that making it harder for
me to hear what might be right about what you're
saying and see what's important. To circle all
the way back around to the dating question,
part of what you're trying to figure out when
you're dating is, well, who are you? What's
different or cool or complimentary about this
new person that I'm getting to know a little bit?
It's really hard and the wake of a breakup
because the baseline that you're comparing to
is someone that incredibly well and have a ton
of history, and it's really hard to close that
gap when that person is the baseline. I'm curious
about your reactions to that. Another question is,
who am I in this relationship as it's starting
to develop? Do I like the way that I am in this
relationship and the way I'm showing up.
Tim Ferriss: That's a big one for me.
Sheila Heen: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Right. Does this person help me to
be a better version of myself, or is this person
sort of summoning the demons of my lesser self?
Sheila Heen: Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: That's a real thing.
Sheila Heen: It's a real thing. And I'll name
the third thing, and then we'll come back to this
thing, which is just, okay, what's the you plus
me combination? How authentic and honest are we
being with each other? Do I know what to expect?
Do I know how you feel? Do you know how I feel,
et cetera? And how do we handle the inevitable
friction that we're going to have? Because in
any combination of two people, you've got
lots of things that are complementary and
some things that are going to have some friction
just because you have really different preferences
and habits and interests and whatever.
In how we handle that, does it bring out
the better part of me or the worst part of me
and vice versa? And does it feel fair also,
or does it feel like one of us is always the one
who has to apologize or to change? And so say a
little bit more about bringing out the better
parts of you and the worst parts of you.
Tim Ferriss: Well, let me preface that by saying I
did a Q&A with some of my audience yesterday. And
if my talking about relationship stuff on the
podcast could be a Rorschach test, holy shit,
do I get a lot of stuff projected on me. There
were so many questions like, "Tim, why can't
you hold onto a partner?" Da, da, da, da, da.
"What happened? Why can't you learn the lesson
about this, this, and this?" All of these things.
I would just say just briefly that I actually,
if you were to talk to my last few exes, who I'm
still on good terms with, they would, I think,
all say that I'm a really good boyfriend. I'm
not perfect, but I talk about this in the same
way that I might, if I had an expert on language
learning on, I would ask them how I could improve
in language learning, even though I think I'm
pretty good at it and have a demonstrated track
record. I would still want to be better because I
know there's room for improvement. I just want to
set the table a little bit so that I maybe stem
the flow of, "Tim, why can't you figure anything
out in relationship" type questions in my open
Q&A sessions that I do every once in a while.
But to come back to —
Sheila Heen: You are naming that that's really,
why can't I figure out? Because it's easier for
me to see it you not figuring something out. But
partly my seeing that is motivated by in my own
life. Why can't I figure out what's going wrong
in my own relationship or where I'm stuck? Or it
might be I was stuck for a long time and gosh,
I want to help you. But it's hard for us to see.
Tim Ferriss: A lot of it's people
vomiting their own stuff.
Sheila Heen: Totally. It's
totally a Rorschach test.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, yes,
and yes. I would say that more than almost any
of the questions or criteria you mentioned,
the one that gives me a clear signal is, "Do I
like who I am around this person?" That's it. And
some matches work better than others, obviously.
Some combinations are better than others,
and sometimes there are massive trade-offs.
Maybe you have excellent chemistry with someone,
but it's also so combustible and the communication
is probably sort of handicapped in some way
that's going to be disastrous ultimately. Right?
The read that I ask though, because it's something
that I can confirm myself. If I ask a question
about someone else or I make an assumption, for
instance, that based on how they're interacting
in a first or second date, I think they're going
to be really bad at deescalating conflict. They
seem to step on top of — if they seem to interrupt
and step on top of me a lot, I might say, "It
seems like X." And they say, "Oh, wow. Well,
you said I hated or loved X." And I'd say, "Well,
actually, no. That's a very exaggerated version
of what I just said, but those are not my words."
And getting this taste test, I might infer that
they would be bad at deescalating conflict, but I
can't really know that for sure based on a first
date. Maybe they're just nervous. Maybe they had
too much coffee. Who knows? I can assess though
how I feel, hopefully with higher fidelity.
I pay attention to that because I think it's
a more reliable, knowable, defensible feeling or
assessment. I do pay a lot of attention to that.
Right? Is someone dredging up all the stuff
that I haven't had to deal with for a while?
Now, it's not to say I can easily point the
causality. Maybe there are other things that
are happening that day, or that week, or that
month that have set the conditions. Or, do I
feel at ease? Are we laughing easily together,
et cetera? Am I feeling good about who I am with
this person, is very much at the top of my list.
Sheila Heen: Yeah, and part of what I love about
that is that you're paying attention to what is
being called forward. Years ago, I was in one
of those on again, off again, break up, get back
together, terrible relationships that I couldn't
quite see my way out of at the time, and my mom,
who doesn't tend to say much explicitly, my mom
gave lots of generalized coaching and instruction
to us as kids, but she wouldn't tend to comment on
something specific happening in the moment. She'd
give general advice. It was up to you to figure
out, "Oh, this is one of those things."
Tim Ferriss: Where it applied?
Sheila Heen: Yeah, one of those things. She'd
kind of leave you alone in the middle of it.
But in the middle of it, she said to me one
night, "At this stage, I don't know that it's
supposed to be this hard." Somehow that was
the light bulb that was like, "Yeah. Actually,
it's not supposed to be this hard, this
early." I was so appreciative at the time,
and it was just an observation, so I'll also then
observe that focusing on, "Gosh, where is this?
I'm really enjoying the conversation. This is
really bringing forward my best self," then sits
in tension with, and what happens when we get
in conflict because then it doesn't test that
sometimes. So what's your experience with that?
Tim Ferriss: Totally. Well, I would say that
there's someone trying to make you
feel good. It's not that hard if we
just go with the heteronormative thing for
a second. If a woman laughs at your jokes,
you feel great. So it's not hard for a woman
to realize that and play that hand very well.
There's someone trying to make you feel good,
and then there's just how you feel from a state
perspective being around them, being exposed
to them. And so I would say it doesn't show you
the play by play of how something will unfold
in conflict. And if someone is over-the-top
cheerful all the time, that is definitely a
yellow flag for me because that isn't reality.
And when the pendulum swings really far in that
towards the mask of everything is always great,
in my experience, tends to swing very hard back
in the other direction equally into the darkness,
so I'm cautious around that. But I would say that
if someone can make me feel physiologically calm
and relaxed and that is a byproduct of their
personality, not necessarily the words they
say or how they laugh at my jokes, that, that
often I think is a foreshadowing of having a
more easeful time in conflict.
Sheila Heen: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: If I am less activated by the
combination of our two personalities in general,
when things are heightened, I will probably
be more heightened, but maybe not DEFCON 5,
in which case I will just be able to speak,
listen, pause, suggest we table things for a
while, and come back to them when we're a little
deescalated more effectively. At least that's how,
suppose I'm thinking about it now
that I have to put words to it.
Sheila Heen: And you're reminding me of something
that we were talking about last time and that
you've mentioned today as well, which is working
something through to resolution. And I'm curious
about what resolution feels like or looks like.
In other words, I think in lots of interactions
in relationship, someone is saying, "Hey, you
did that thing again. And by the way, I just
want to note I'm annoyed right now because," fill
in the blank, and noting it helps me actually say,
"And we don't have to talk about it now, but I
just needed to name it so that I don't instead
act passive aggressively annoyed about it and
pretend I'm not." And then can we live in that
space? Can we hold that space and we don't have
to totally unpack it right this very minute?
And sometimes that's enough. It's a chronic
thing between us and I'm just noting it. And
can we live in that space, both of us? Do we feel
equally comfortable or does one of us say, "Well,
now that you've said you're annoyed, we've got
to stop everything and spend a couple of hours
unpacking it." And what's our preference there?
Tim Ferriss: That's my nightmare.
Sheila Heen: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I mean,
I kind of feel like a lot of processing, just
like a lot of presentations, fail from too much
information, not too little information in the
sense that what does resolution look like to me,
if that's the question? I would answer
that I think the simplest way to achieve
resolution is to have some agreement of
what that looks like in a shared framework,
something out of one of your books or
something from Getting the Love You Want,
where there are actual triage tools that have
determined endpoints. Whether the endpoint is,
"I just want to say this right now, we don't need
to address it. I'm not asking for processing,
but could we schedule a time to talk about it?"
Great, episode complete. I'm not saying that
as the one and only tool. The tool could be some
version of Nonviolent Communication where when X,
Y, and Z happened, I felt this. The story I make
around that is this, could I ask you blank? Having
a clear request and agreement and then episode
complete. So I think it's just having a mutual
agreement as to what those exchanges look like.
And I mean, a question that I want to ask,
because this came up in a number of places
in our last conversation, but we didn't
dig into this one piece in particular,
it's related to a line that I'll read,
and there are a few different versions of this,
but "given Gottman's research, about two-thirds
of our conflicts and long-term relationships
are not really resolvable. The task isn't to
resolve them once and for all. It's to figure
out a way to handle them or navigate them and
manage them together that feels okay and good."
To zoom out, I do want to ask you about that and
specifically is the only way to figure that out
to basically be with someone for six months or
a year. But broadly speaking, I'm wondering what
you think of the Gottman Institute. They get cited
all the time because I'm sure people have heard,
and I'm going to get the specifics wrong here,
but that the founders of the Gottman Institute
could look at five minutes of video footage of a
couple, and with 95 percent plus accuracy,
predict who would be divorced within the
next three years or whatever it might be.
People have heard these anecdotes. What is
the Gottman Institute and what do you think the
strengths and weaknesses are to the extent that
you've been able to glean either of those things?
Sheila Heen: Yeah. Well, so I think that the work
that they're doing is fascinating and additive and
there just aren't, particularly when they started,
there weren't people really studying marriage
and long-term relationships, good, bad,
and everything in-between. So there might be
talk about why did things break down but you
weren't also looking at what was working for other
couples. And from my point of view, of course,
they're focused on what's most important,
which is that they are inviting couples in,
they're inviting them to talk about a topic that
is stressful. So they're inviting them to have a
difficult conversation and they're hooking them
up to heart monitors and all of that. And then
they're recording all that data and then they're
following the couple and noticing what correlates
with either self-reporting being happily married
and doing that over time. Because sometimes people
will self-report being happily married and then
they divorce and then they're going back and
saying, "Well, actually I wasn't happily married,"
which may be revisionist memory, but also maybe
it was good enough for me to be happy, but then we
weren't talking about what we needed to talk about
because there's a portion of those that are —
Tim Ferriss: The good was good enough,
but the bad wasn't being addressed.
Sheila Heen: Right, exactly. The bad
wasn't being addressed. So it felt like, "Well, we
never argued about anything." Well, it's because
one of us wasn't speaking up to say the things
that were bothering us because it was good enough.
So I think that the work that they're doing is
incredibly valuable and it's very descriptive,
meaning it's identifying what are the variables.
So eye-rolling is one of the things that is
most closely correlated with the relationship
fraying and divorce, partly because eye-rolling
is just an external indicator of internal,
"Here we go again. I'm not really listening
anymore." What they code as contempt.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, very — I'm
not aware of a single culture where
eye-rolling has a positive indication.
Sheila Heen: Right, exactly. Exactly. So what
they're doing is that they're identifying and
describing what correlates with a relationship
ending or seeming to have staying power. What
I love about that is that it lines up so
nicely with the prescriptive work that we do,
the diagnostic and prescriptive work that we do
to take a look at, well, what's really going on
that's getting us stuck? Why am I rolling my eyes?
Because I feel frustrated, unheard, we're falling
back into our usual pattern where I don't expect
there to be a resolution, and I'm exhausted by
that and I don't know how to get out of it. So it
lines up nicely with our observations about what
gets people stuck and also then what helps. But
it gives us insight through another lens about the
longer term impact of that. The fact that about
a third of the conflicts tend to be temporal,
you can say that they're resolvable or just we
move on because we had to decide where to live,
and we decided, and now we're —
Tim Ferriss: Transient.
They have an expiration date.
Sheila Heen: We're not arguing about that
anymore. We needed to figure out how to parent
young children. We no longer have young children.
Now we'll just have conflicts about how to parent
older children. So two thirds are just reflective
of the particularities of you plus me and where
we're going to have some rub. And the question of
are we able to notice that, note it and hold it
with some humor and affection for each other in
the midst of it, even as we're honest and direct
about you doing that thing again. And do we feel
like, I feel seen and heard, and it's a relatively
balanced sense of sometimes you get your way,
sometimes I get my way, and we're slowly, it's
getting to be a less loaded topic rather than
a more loaded topic. What's your experience
with the loaded topics and eye-rolling, maybe?
Tim Ferriss: I have very low tolerance
for eye-rolling. I just don't have
time for people who behave that way. So that's a
one-strike-you're-out kind of situation. There are
too many amazing people in the world, and there
are too many people who don't do that also. There
are plenty of people who don't engage with that.
Let me preface, I'm going to ask a clarifying
question about your question, but I will
say that I was thinking about it a bit as
you were discussing the Gottman Institute that
I don't say this much, but I've probably said
it a half a dozen times, observing couples
at dinners or at weddings where I'm like,
"They will be divorced within three
years." 100 percent accurate thus far.
Sheila Heen: Yes. Yes. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Although
I don't think it takes —
Sheila Heen: You should
just be deputized to let people know.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I don't think it — honorary
degree from the Gottman Institute.
Sheila Heen: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: But I honestly don't think it
takes Poirot or Sherlock Holmes to figure
it out. I mean, to me, a lot of it seems pretty
obvious, but the eye-rolling, making jokes that
are at the expense of the other person where you
observe one person laughing who made the joke,
the other person clearly not laughing. Any
type of emasculating, which can go both ways,
but any type of cutting down in a group
environment seems so obviously a recipe
for disaster. But when you say the loaded topics
or how I relate to that, could you phrase that a
different way? What do you mean by that?
Sheila Heen: The topics that are chronic
irritations between us or differences, and then we
make meaning out of that. The fact that you know
this drives me crazy and yet you still continue
to do it, or this is something we disagree
about and it's still not feeling settled or good.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I suppose there are, of course,
different species of chronic unresolved or
maybe unresolvable friction. I would say that I,
certainly, in my last handful of relationships,
and it's not like I've had a ton. I mean, I've had
a few long relationships. We've come to a truce,
I would say, on a lot of those things if we can
laugh at them together, and sometimes they drive
one person or the other crazy. But there are these
manageable differences that can be more often than
not laughed about. I would say for me, as someone
who has always battled chronic fatigue, and I do
think that could be explained partly by multiple
documented infections with Lyme disease, but
there are, I'm sure other contributing factors.
The problem for me is not generally the problem,
unless somebody really betrays trust or something
like that and does something that from the outside
would be considered terrible, clearly terrible,
which I had some degree of, what's the right
word? I would put up with more of that when
I was very young. Like a lot of people, the
exciting person was worth all sorts of drama.
I'm just no longer at that place in my life.
So I don't deal with those types of situations
really. But I would say the problem for me is
frequently not the problem itself, the situation
that is under discussion. It's the method of
discussion and the duration of discussion.
So for me, if constant processing becomes
a defining feature of the relationship,
that is a meta issue for me that is very
difficult to metabolize, which doesn't
mean I don't talk about problems. It's just
we should have a toolkit that allows us to,
and also a degree of independent resilience and
interpersonal resilience, whereby if someone
dropped a piece of gum on the floor and they don't
do it all the time, just pick it up and throw it
out. It's not a big deal. This doesn't require —
Sheila Heen: Accommodate the other person.
Tim Ferriss: Does not require a conversation.
So I would say that for me, most of the issues,
at least those that are coming to mind right
now are not big in and of themselves. But if
the discussion ends up feeling like it's just
going in circles upon circles upon circles,
then I do struggle with it.
Sheila Heen: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That I struggle with, which is
certainly not unique to me. Every couple I know
has some version of this, but certainly my hope is
that with someone I'm with long-term, the majority
of time it does not feel like heavy lifting. Your
mom said to you, "At this point, I'm not sure it
should be this hard," something like that.
Sheila Heen: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And the couples I've talked to
who I really admire, who have been together 15,
20 plus years, generally all come back with some
version of that. It shouldn't be hard all the
time. However, I find them all very difficult
to model because almost without exception,
they met when they were very young.
Neither person had anything. They were
young and stupid and loving life. And they met
through complete luck of the draw circumstance
it would seem. Oftentimes very early, and
sometimes it's like high school or college,
and their lived experience is just very different
from mine. My life doesn't lend itself to as much
of that now as it would when I was 16, 17,
18, 20, early 20s. So I'm not sure how to
model what they've achieved, in other words.
Sheila Heen: Part of what you're making me
think about is a conversation that I had with my
youngest sister who — I got married young. I mean,
I look back now and I'm like, "Why did I think
I had any business getting married at 26?" And
so I'm one of those people who have been married
forever. And I think my husband John and I grew
up together in so many ways. My youngest sister
got married at 38, and when she met her husband,
well, at first she friend zoned him and
he wasn't a contender. And then suddenly
she had this epiphany of like, "Oh, he's
the right person standing in front of me."
Tim Ferriss: He was like, "I can wait. I
have the patience of an insect," as one
of — "The praying mantis will wait."
Sheila Heen: That's right. That's
right. We actually commissioned
a custom song for their wedding,
and it was all about Stacy's big epiphany and how
patient Dan had been. I know you'll come around.
Tim Ferriss: Good for Dan.
Sheila Heen: Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Good for both of them, I guess.
Sheila Heen: Good for both of them. And in
real time, it didn't take that long. It
felt like forever to him. But he then
proposed quite quickly. My parents were
visiting. My sister also lives in Boston,
and she left the room and he suddenly turned to
them and said, "I just wanted to let you know
how much I am in love with your daughter, and I
want to ask her to marry me and spend the rest of
my life with her." And my mother's like, "Well, I
have some follow-up questions." My father's like,
"Be quiet." He said to me later, "I wanted to
leap across the island and kiss him. Yes, we love
you. We think you're awesome." Which reflects
something about each of my parents. But Stacy
in the meantime was out of the room. And so she
then walks back in the room, this is a completely
out-of-the-blue topic of conversation.
Tim Ferriss: They've had
the secret caucus complete.
Sheila Heen: And suddenly it's like,
"Well, okay, I'm going to run down and get a
bottle of champagne," kind of thing. And so
they weren't officially engaged yet, but it
was on the table that they were more or less,
and they had been dating for less than a year.
Tim Ferriss: How long had they
known each other though?
Sheila Heen: About a year.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, all right. A year
before that or it was a year total?
Sheila Heen: Yeah. Well, they met through a mutual
friend at a party. The friend had called Dan to
say, "You need to break up with whoever you're
going out with, because I'm going to introduce
you to someone tonight."
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Sheila Heen: But she didn't know.
Tim Ferriss: Hope they get a
bouquet of flowers every year.
Sheila Heen: Oh, yeah. They have
milked that for all it's worth.
Tim Ferriss: As they should.
Sheila Heen: As they should. And so they knew
each other for a few months before she figured
it out. And then they were dating in earnest.
And then this is probably nine months after that.
So after all the toasts, she and I went for
a run together, and she said, I said, "How
are you feeling?" And she's, "It's just amazing,
and I can hardly believe it." And also I'm still
waiting to find out what's wrong with him. And my
reaction was, "Well, five years from now, you're
going to have a much more robust answer for that
question of what's wrong with him. But the real
question is, are they going to be deal breakers
for you? And what would the deal breakers be?"
And so Tim, I'm curious, given your experience,
partly what you're listening for in the early
stages of dating is are there deal breakers here
for me, not because I'm judging this other person,
but because I just know that that combination's
not going to work or whatever. And so,
one of them sounds like it's endless processing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, endless processing would be
one. And I want to own my part obviously in some
of this, in the sense that I'm sure I contributed
to situations that were uncomfortable enough
for my significant other that she felt the need
to process. However, I do think she also leans
that direction in terms of communication. So yes,
endless processing or a primary project being
processing that is expected to be a dominant
feature of the relationship. Necessary
for sure. But a dominant feature of the
relationship? No, I think that it shouldn't
feel that hard. And if it does, chances are
there are things that are probably irreconcilable
differences. So that would be one deal breaker.
Other deal breakers? If somebody throws
sharp elbows, that's really what I'm very
wary of for a lot of reasons. But if somebody
throws sharp elbows, if they are vindictive,
if they speak in a really aggressive, upset way
about their exes, those are all red flags for me,
not yellow. Those are red. And it's astonishing
what some people, and I'm grateful they do,
but what some people will volunteer on first
dates in terms of, "Oh, yeah, my ex did this
and I showed him by taking a torch and doing
this and this and this." And I'm like, "Okay,
hope you enjoyed your chicken salad because this
has been swell. Thank you." So the sharp elbows,
somebody who's in any way vindictive is a deal
breaker. I would say if someone is a monologuer,
that's also deal breaker. I want somebody who
is a good listener, good asker of questions. I
think men tend to do this a lot more than women,
the monologuing. But I've seen some exceptions.
Sheila Heen: I've dated some exceptions.
Tim Ferriss: Monologuers, overtalkers.
People who step on me or other people when
they are mid-thought to interject or one up,
that gets exhausting. Those would be a
few that come to mind. I'm sure there
are others, but those are a few that
immediately leap to mind when you ask.
Sheila Heen: Part of what you're describing
is something that the Gottman Institute would
reinforce, which is that what are our
implicit rules about conflict? And that
the couples that have staying power tend to have
boundaries on, no matter how upset I am with you,
there are some places that I don't go
because in a long-term partnership you
know each other so well that you also have
the capacity to really hurt the other person.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Sheila Heen: And part of because you
know what would hurt them? And you secretly think
it sometimes, especially when you're frustrated,
and that even in those moments, you don't
go somewhere that is gratuitously that
sharp elbow or vindictiveness or meanness.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. You don't turn it into a
Quentin Tarantino action sequence. It's not —
Sheila Heen: Yeah. And it's always amazing to
me that they're actually —
Tim Ferriss: Kill Bill.
Sheila Heen: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: — all of a sudden.
Sheila Heen: Suddenly, you didn't know
it, but I was wearing that yellow suit —
Tim Ferriss: The yellow jumpsuit.
Sheila Heen: — jumpsuit under my
pajamas tonight. So I think that the boundaries
that we each assume on how we handle the hardest
moments, those being shared boundaries, feels —
— those being shared boundaries feels like a wise
guideline to have for yourself. The other thing
that I was thinking about about your processing
point is that for me it feels like, boy, there's
a long period during which we're bumping into each
other and where there's some friction between
us, processing it to understand it better. What
was going on with me that I did interrupt you
— which by the way, interrupting is one of the
feedback things I give my husband because he's
a big interrupter, which makes me crazy, crazy.
That means in part — see, I'm blaming him for this
— that I am an interrupter, because if I don't get
my word in edgewise, I'm not going to get in.
I think as a woman and a professional in some
of the spaces I'm in, being willing to speak up to
get into the conversation when there's a moment to
do so has in many contexts served me pretty well,
and in other contexts and other relationships, I'm
doing to other people exactly the thing that he
does to me, my husband does to me, that makes me
so want to kill him. The Kill Bill comes to mind.
I think the question of understanding, gosh,
what's going on with me, when does it happen,
what's going on with him, what does it happen,
that kind of processing can be helpful.
Then there's a point where we've talked
about it a hundred times, we've dissected it a
hundred times, and we're back doing the thing
that triggers the reaction. It just is. It just
is. There's a point where you have to decide,
and for me, the switch is he's changed as
much as he's going to change, or I've changed
as much as I'm going to be able to change.
I do it maybe less often or he does it less
often. I'll still do it sometimes, and misstep.
If I assume this person is not going to change,
can I live with that? Can we each live with
that? If so, then it's easier to have the,
"Let me just note, you did that thing again."
"Oh, you're right. I apologize." We can talk
about it later if we need to and we can move on,
because we don't need to reprocess something that
we have already processed and we're at the
limits of how much each of us is going to be
able to change sometimes, in some moments.
Tim Ferriss: Totally. What occurred to me
as you're talking also is that people like to
do what they're good at. The big strong guys
like to go to the weight room. The flexy people
like to go do yoga. The debaters like to debate,
and the people who are on some level good at, say,
emotional processing like to emotionally process.
Sheila Heen: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: If that is part of their identity,
then you are signing up for that. I think I
somewhat knowingly, somewhat unknowingly, probably
signed up for that, and she is very, very good at
it. It was, I think, a constitutional — meaning
personal constitution — mismatch of sorts.
Sheila Heen: Not a national Constitutional issue.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Not talking about the
Second Amendment here. Relax, everybody. Yeah,
people like to do what they're good at,
and I need to be cautious about that too,
right? Because my response to some of that would
often be to try to put her in a cattle chute to
get her into this logic puzzle where I knew I
would be better. I'd try to steer her into some
labyrinth of spreadsheets and analytics because
I'm better at that stuff, and that wasn't helpful.
It was hugely counterproductive, I'm sure, at many
different points, but that's what I'm good at.
More and more, I've tried to cultivate an
awareness of what I do because I am good at
said thing, whatever that is, which applies
to not just relationships, but also how you
structure your day and your week and choose
your projects. Are you choosing these things
because they're truly the most important, or are
you choosing these things because you happen to
have some skill and therefore it's comfortable for
you to do these things? I think about that a lot.
Sheila Heen: I just want to make an observation
about what you just said which was so insightful,
and where you feel comfortable and what you're
good at. Because for some people — and I don't
know her, so I don't know if it's true of
her — but for some people, part of what
makes them feel safe or secure or reassured in a
relationship is to rock the boat. I've had some
relationships like that, and rocking the boat so
that we have something to process helps me feel
connected to you. It's redemonstrating
that you care, and that processing,
emotional processing, goes to a place that feels
comfortable to me and feels reassuring to me.
In that place — if we go back to the three
positions, which is just, there's my perspective,
which is obviously correct. Then there's the other
person's perspective, the second position. And
they're inside their story, and their world, and
why they think they're correct. And then either
both of us could step to the third position.
What would a neutral observer say about what's
going on and what might help us get through this?
She's in the place where, "I want to be connected
with you. We need to be ourselves connecting
in the first and second position," and the
place where you go because you feel more
comfortable might be the third position,
to step out, to be analytical about it,
to say, "Well, let me just step back to
understand what's happening here, because if
I can understand what's happening here..."
Tim Ferriss: That's exactly what I do.
Sheila Heen: "...then I have advice for
myself about where to go," and she's like,
"Don't leave me here." You're disconnecting
to go to the balcony or the third position.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. You should do this for
a living. Kidding, kidding.
Sheila Heen: That's the way
in which that processing also was not serving
its purpose for her, and was not where you felt
you wanted to be or what she was asking of you.
Tim Ferriss: That resonates as very on-point. I
would further say that I contributed to
that by, for most of our relationship,
being very weak in terms of her love language
of words of affirmation. It would make sense
to me that with a deficit, with a lack
or a deficiency of words of affirmation,
that one — could be male, female, doesn't matter
— would want to rock the boat to elicit that
type of connection in processing, to get those
words of affirmation. I think I almost certainly
contributed to that very directly in that way.
Sheila Heen: Yeah. I have that same profile.
That's a weakness for me also. I see it showing
up in my personal relationships as well as my
work relationships. I'm pushing myself more.
Tim Ferriss: Giving words of affirmation?
Sheila Heen: Yeah. My family was
not a super demonstrative family,
to feel the need to say it out loud.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, same.
Sheila Heen: It's changing.
Tim Ferriss: How are you working on that? How do
you work on that? I'm curious. I mean, I have
improved. I'm still very much on training wheels,
but I have made substantial improvement, I think.
How are you working on it, or what have you found
helpful to work on, giving words of affirmation,
positive reinforcement? Because I did not grow up
with a whole lot of that, and very much learned to
do without it in say sports as well, and in skill
development. I trained myself not to really
require it and to be intrinsically motivated,
so I then expect that of most people, which is an
unfair expectation. It just doesn't map to reality
very well. How have you worked on it?
Sheila Heen: Some of it is just with
conscious reminders to myself to do it.
Tim Ferriss: Just like a timer on your phone,
an index card with five lines, that you can pull
out and be like, "Hold on. John." No, I'm kidding.
Sheila Heen: Well, you're kidding.
Tim Ferriss: That's the
kind of thing that I might do.
Sheila Heen: Honest to God, yeah. It's also trying
to get better at noticing in myself when I do feel
grateful for something somebody did. If I get an
email that I'm just like, "Oh, my God, that is
so helpful," just to remember to say it out loud.
The other thing is to just shoot them back a note
to say, "Thank you so much for taking the time it
took to send this to me, because it's incredibly
helpful," and that's all it needs to be. I also
noticed that I'm better at it in writing than
I am verbally, so that's okay if that's where
the training wheels are, to remember to just
text, to say when I notice something specific.
That's something we didn't talk about about
appreciation, which is just to seem genuine. Like,
"Great job," isn't very genuine.
Tim Ferriss: Compelling.
Sheila Heen: Being specific — yeah, compelling.
It doesn't sound necessarily sincere. Being
specific helps. Also just like, "Hey, I
particularly appreciated your note," or,
"I thought your whatever had a really big
impact on me." I think the more I can just
notice the small things that are specific,
the better. That's helped me. I don't know,
do you have other tips? Because I could use them.
Tim Ferriss: I was exaggerating a bit with the
index card, but for a while — and I could
probably use with doing more of this — I
would literally put in a calendar reminders, like,
"Say something nice to this person, this person,
this person." There's always something I
can think of that is specific, and I just,
for whatever malfunction, through being a
little nicer to myself, conditioning through my
upbringing, neglected to mention, then I would
mention. I'd literally put it in my calendar,
and I found that helpful. I did find it helpful.
Sheila Heen: I also am appreciating your
connecting this to maybe what was going on
that caused the, "Hey, we need processing,
I need reassurance, because I'm not sure where
I stand or I felt overlooked or not seen,"
et cetera, which part of what I'm learning is that
when I have somebody who is frustrated or upset,
it is often that they are also feeling
underappreciated, and that's on me.
Tim Ferriss: Totally. Let me ask you a bit
about giving feedback instead of receiving,
and I know we've touched on this indirectly and
maybe even directly in this conversation, but for
people who are in the supervisor, boss — or it
could be a significant other, but we've spent a
bunch of time on the personal. Let's talk about
the professional, even though they're two sides
of the same coin. If you are giving feedback to
someone who tends to be sensitive, I'll just set
the stage — this is not actually really the case
for me right now in any capacity, but it has been
at various points with employees, with significant
others — what are your suggestions for giving
feedback, and how to open that door hopefully
in a way that doesn't immediately provoke or
exacerbate a really defensive type of kickback?
Sheila Heen: One foundation thing is have the
two of you had a conversation about how
they prefer to get feedback? That can be
one of the most helpful and powerful things
to do, which is to sit down talk about, "Hey,
what makes you feel appreciated?" Some people need
to hear the words. Other people don't really care
about the words, but the fact that you come
to them for advice with some of your toughest
problems, or you would like their input on your
proofreading, tells them they're valued. "What
makes you feel appreciated? If I have coaching
for you, what's your advice to me on when and
how to give it? Do you have pet peeves about
feedback generally?" We all have pet peeves.
That's a really interesting conversation to
have. "When you're triggered by feedback,
how can I tell? How will I be able
to tell? It might be totally obvious,
but sometimes people shut down, and I can't tell
whether you're taking it in or arguing in your
head. When you are triggered or feeling defensive,
what advice do you have for me on what will help?"
We have a little template that's like, "How to
get the best out of me," that each of us can
jot down some thoughts to and then talk about.
Tim Ferriss: How to get the best out of me. Is
that a template that is available online
or that we could put in the show notes?
Sheila Heen: Yeah, on the Triad consulting
website, triadconsultinggroup.com. We have
a nav called "Help Yourself," and it's got
a bunch of templates, exercises, et cetera.
Tim Ferriss: Great. We'll link to that.
Sheila Heen: Just having that conversation
up front means I don't have to guess at how to
give you feedback because already told me, and
hopefully I've taken some notes which I keep handy
to remind myself. I can refer back, like, "Hey,
I had a couple of thoughts about the presentation
last week, and I wonder when it would be helpful
to chat about it a little bit," or whatever.
The second thing is that really the fastest way
to change a feedback culture and to help people
be more receptive is to become a good receiver
yourself, and be soliciting and eliciting feedback
from others. To assume every conversation, even
when I think I'm pretty clearly the giver here,
I'm probably going to end up being a receiver,
because what they're going to say is, "Well,
the reason I did that is you were so unclear
about what you wanted," or whatever.
I have to assume there are things I've
contributed to the situation that are going to
be part of the conversation, even when for me,
the primary purpose is to tell you what I
think you could do differently or better.
There's a question that we use a lot that I think
is incredibly helpful just in building a habit of
integrating feedback into daily life, which is
not, "Hey, do you have any feedback for me,"
which we've talked about is a terrible question,
well-intended but terrible. Particularly from a
leader, because giving feedback up feels very
risky and fraught. If you are in a position
of leadership, you are impacting more and more
people, and fewer and fewer of them are going
to take the chance to tell you about it. You've
got to actually have some pretty advanced skills
in receiving feedback and inviting it.
One way you can do that is to ask,
"What's one thing? What's one thing that I'm
doing or maybe failing to do that you think
is getting in the way, or what's one thing that,
if I could change it, would make a difference to
you? Or what's one thing that, in our Monday
morning meeting, we could change to make it
more efficient, because I know people
are flagging, their energy's flagging?"
That's a question that you can toss
off while you're walking down the hall,
and it lowers the stakes. It's very clear you're
asking for coaching. You're looking for something
to improve. You're also signaling, "By the way,
I expect you to be receptive to coaching also,
because I'm going to demonstrate I
value it. I assume I'm still learning,
and I expect that you're still learning too."
Tim Ferriss: One thing. One thing.
Sheila Heen: What's one thing?
Tim Ferriss: It's funny how one thing at a time,
put in sequence, how much that can do.
Sheila Heen: It's not is there anything,
because if you ask is there anything, people
will be like, "Oh, no, you're great. We love
working with you." You have to assume there is.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. That's kind of like my,
"If you had to cut 20 percent, what
would you cut?" Not "Would you cut?"
Sheila Heen: Yeah, that's one of the
reasons that's such a great question.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's forced. It applies some
very clear constraints. The option of not naming
something is not implicit in that question.
Sheila Heen: That's fair. Do you get people
who ignore the question anyway?
Tim Ferriss: No, because they make
terrible proofreaders. Generally my friends know.
These are people I've known for a while typically,
so they know exactly what they're signing
up for, and they know what type of feedback
I have given them in the past also.
Sheila Heen: Right, so it's reciprocal?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
They have a very good idea of exactly what I'm
looking for and they'll ask clarifying questions
if need be, but what is one thing, dot-dot-dot,
is a really useful heuristic for getting the
type of feedback that may not be forthcoming,
especially if you are at the top of the pyramid
or in the hierarchy in a leadership position.
Well, Sheila, we've covered a lot. What have we
not covered? Is there anything that you would like
to discuss before we begin to wind to a close?
Have we neglected anything that pops to mind?
We've certainly gone through a lot of different
scenarios. We've gone through the interpersonal,
we've gone through intimate relationships,
we've gone through professional environments.
Is there any particular point that comes
to mind or anything you'd like to add,
before we begin to land the plane?
Sheila Heen: What's in my head is maybe
a follow-on to what you just said about the one
thing and being in leadership, which is, so when
we were working on the feedback book, part
of the challenge is that the need to give
feedback is a felt problem. I have feedback
for you. I'm carrying it around with myself
because I don't know how to give it to you,
or I've tried to give it to you and you're
not taking it. If there's a book that would help
me do that, I would buy that book, and could use
some help. The need to receive feedback from other
people who are carrying it around and not giving
it to us is not necessarily a felt problem. I'm
oblivious to it. I have mixed feelings about it.
Tim Ferriss: It's like carbon
monoxide, the invisible killer.
Sheila Heen: That's right. It is the
invisible killer. Actually that's a very
good metaphor for it. Do I want a carbon
monoxide detector? I do. I know I should.
Tim Ferriss: You do.
Sheila Heen: It's also moving
from a push model of learning — I decide what you
need to learn and I push you to learn it — to a
pull model of learning, which is I'm curious what
you think I have to learn or could improve, which
is very much your stance, Tim. It's very relaxing
to be with someone who has that stance, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's also — and I think
your book does a great job of this — I mean,
it is a learnable skill. I learned this
through skill acquisition, where for instance,
I would need to have to turn laypeople,
non-coaches, into coaches. To do that,
you have to elicit with lots of very specific
questions and very well-thought-through questions.
For instance, if you want a native speaker to help
you learn your target language, that is actually
a very big ask and very challenging if they're
not trained teachers. If you go up to a native
English speaker and you're like, "Tell me the
difference between anything and something," or,
"When do you use an versus the when it's a
new person being introduced," to a sense. Most
native English speakers would fail the test of
English as a foreign language, or do very poorly.
It would be so confusing, because what is
reflexive is not something they can explain.
I think I've developed that stance through a lot
of repetitions with mostly different skills. It
is not something that came intuitively, but
it is something that you can pick up very,
very quickly with the right toolkit.
Sheila Heen: With that toolkit,
you become an incredibly skilled and fast learner.
I think that's a big aha for me, which is, "Oh,
gosh, I can learn from anybody. They don't have to
be a skilled giver, because I can help with that
to hear and understand what they're trying to tell
me, and then I can figure out what to make of it,
and what I want to take away and leave behind."
The last thing on this front is that as leaders,
sometimes people will say, "Well, I don't
really know what I should be working on."
My answer to them is like, "Well, you know
who knows? Pretty much everybody else."
Everybody around you has a list of the things you
do to make it harder for them to do their job.
It's a list they pass amongst each other about
you. It becomes the conventional wisdom about you,
what's great about you and what's hard about
working with you. If you want to know what's on
that list, you have to ask, and you have to ask
in a way that persuades them that you actually
want to know and you'll take it seriously.
You can't promise that you can change it or
you would change it, but at least listening
for the themes that you hear from different
people at different times will help identify
the things that, "Oh, yeah, that's probably
something that's not helping in this context."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. This topic of feedback in
Thanks for the Feedback: The Science and Art of
Receiving Feedback Well, it's a bit of a Trojan
horse for a bunch of things, as you mentioned,
right? If you want to be a super learner,
it doesn't just apply to interacting with
your boss at work. It doesn't just apply to
your direct reports at work. It doesn't just
apply to your significant other. It actually
applies in a million different contexts.
How can you elicit the feedback that will
most help you to take constructive next steps? I
mean, it applies to everything. To that extent,
it's very much a meta skill, that is transferable
across a million different disciplines.
Sheila, people can find the Triad Consulting Group
at triadconsultinggroup.com. I also did go to the
Help Yourself, you have all sorts of tools and
links available on the Help Yourself portion of
that website, so people can go there. Is there
anywhere else you would like to point people?
Sheila Heen: Well, so I've been trying to get
better at social media and LinkedIn. Triad has
a LinkedIn page and I now have a LinkedIn
page, and I try to post occasionally and
get more than occasionally. I think that the
question of where do I get help with this,
we also have a list of what's on our shelf. You
do too, Tim. We have a lot of overlap in the
kinds of things that you are reading and thinking
about, and this journey is such a central one that
there's lots of different resources out there.
I'll double-check to see if our latest list of
resources, things that we would recommend, is up.
Tim Ferriss: Great. We'll link in the show notes
then to certainly Thanks for the Feedback,
the book and books, Triad Consulting Group,
and then to the respective LinkedIn pages, for
people who would like to explore. We'll put those
at tim.blog/podcast as per usual. Any last words
before we go? I'll say thank you very much for the
time, as always. Have enjoyed the conversation
immensely and am taking copious notes.
Sheila Heen: Well, yeah. I am thinking about
your dating project and journey, and so I'll be
interested to hear how it goes, and also what you
find that cuts to the heart of, "What do I want to
understand about this person and about myself in a
way that we show up together that is either super
energizing and rewarding and fun," which is how
it should be, "or anxiety-provoking and draining?"
Tim Ferriss: Yes, I would strongly prefer to
lean heavily in the former grouping instead
of the latter. I'll keep you posted
on my progress in that department.
Sheila Heen: Perfect. Perfect.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you so much
for taking the time.
Sheila Heen: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: Always such a pleasure. To everybody
listening, you've heard this before. Until next
time, be just a bit kinder than is necessary,
not only to others, but to yourself. "Know
thyself," as the sign would say over the Oracle at
Delphi. Part of that is learning how to elicit and
metabolize good feedback, so take a close look
at it. Until next time, thanks for tuning in.